hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast depth at the biological
variable and microbial pathogenesis
presented by dr. Sabra Kline associate
professor molecular microbiology and
immunology biochemistry and molecular
biology Johns Hopkins Bloomberg School
of Public Health we are excited to bring
you this educational webcast presented
by Lavery's the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
find Julie simmer off of LaBrie and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located and the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower left if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the ze button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage then follow the process
of obtaining your credits now please
join me in welcoming dr. Sabra Klein I
will now turn the presentation over to
her Thank You Julie I am thrilled to be
a part of this educational webinar and
to raise awareness that there are
differences between males and females in
our immune system and how our immune
system combats microbial infections I
have no conflicts of interest to
disclose in this presentation I'd like
to begin our discussion today with the
simple idea that although males and
females
identical immune systems we have the
same immune cells the same proteins the
same pathways that respond to the
presence of a virus as we have indicated
here in this cartoon image or a
bacterial parasite even an allergen or
self at antigen what we find is that
even though both males and females have
similar immune systems responding to
these antigens the magnitude of these
responses can differ significantly so
what we have listed here on the y-axis
is magnitude of response and I'd like
for you to follow along as we walk
through a typical immune response that
we would expect to see in this case
following a viral infection the first
thing that happens is that pattern
recognition receptors abbreviated prr
have to be in place to recognize the
presence of a foreign virus in our
system immediately with the recognition
of the presence of a virus by pattern
recognition receptors data from my
laboratory and others have already
indicated that these responses are
higher and faster in cells from females
as compared with males these what we
would call innate immune cells that
possess these pattern recognition
receptors then initiate an innate immune
response with production of cytokines as
well as chemokines both of which have
been shown to be elicited to a greater
degree in cells from females as compared
with males the initiation of this innate
immune response leads to the activation
of lymphocytes including our t-cells as
well as our B cells which are going to
be important because these are gonna be
the cells that are gonna produce the
responses that will be necessary for
elimination of the virus so we're gonna
have antibody production by our b-cells
effector responses by our cd4 positive T
cells as well as our cd8 positive T
cells
that again are going to be important for
initiation of the responses necessary to
eliminate a virus all of which as shown
in the pink are higher in females as
compared with males so this would appear
that females must have a better immune
response well more is not always better
where things start to change is when we
look at the return to homeostasis and
the production of what I'm referring to
as regulatory responses these regulatory
responses which can include cells like
our regulatory t-cells proteins like
Isleton and tgf-beta or even receptors
receptor interactions like the
engagement of pbl one with its receptor
PD one all of which tend to be higher in
males as compared with females so with
the increase in these regulatory
responses the return of our tissues and
cells to the state of homeostasis being
if you will faster or more efficient in
males as compared with females
what I have indicated at the end of our
time graphic is that the risk of disease
can differ for males and females
depending on the etiology of that
disease I'm going to come back to this
in a moment but let's move on and talk
about different infectious diseases
there are definitely sex and gender
related differences in infectious
disease outcomes between males and
females I separate sex and gender
because among humans it can often be
very difficult to tease apart what is
due to our biological differences that
define us as being males and females
between would refer to as our sex versus
these social or cultural norms that may
define us as exhibiting male light or
female like behaviors and in humans this
can be very difficult to differentiate
but when I am showing again in this
table that was published
recently in 2016 these are data all from
humans from viruses bacteria parasites
as well as fungi and showing male/female
differences with a male bias being
indicated in blue
a female bias being indicated in red if
an analysis was conducted conducted
excuse me but no difference was observed
this is indicated in gray and where
nobody has bothered to look to see if
there are male/female differences this
is indicated by the ND or not determined
in the cell if we look at the intensity
of infections what we see across diverse
pathogens is that majority of studies do
not bother to look and statistically
compared males and females to determine
if the pathogen burden which is what we
would use to define the intensity of an
infection differs between males and
females where investigators have looked
for HIV for hepatitis Plasmodium and
fungal infections males often had a
higher intensity of infection as
compared with females if we look at the
prevalence or the incidence of infection
so this is the proportion of individuals
within a population that are positive
for a particular pathogen here we could
see how not only our biology but our
behavior could influence these
differences we find that by and large
males have a higher prevalence or
incidence of infection as compared with
females with for some pathogens
including lepto as well as several
parasitic and fungal infections no
observed biases have been reported
lastly if we look at the column labeled
severity what we find is that it's a
mixed bag with red indicating a female
biased blue indicating a male bias we
can first see and I am encouraged to say
that many investigators have looked to
see whether there are male/female
differences in the severity of infection
but when we
but collectively across diverse
pathogens we find that for some
pathogens the severity of infection is
worse for females whereas for other
infections the severity is worse for
males so now let's discuss my hypothesis
as to why the severity of infection
sometimes shows a female bias whereas in
other cases shows a male bias and I
think this goes back to what I had
mentioned earlier the etiology of
disease following infection and what we
find when we look at the etiology of
infectious diseases is that host damage
which in this cartoon is illustrated as
ranging from a high level of damage to a
low level of damage I have this graphed
against our immune response so our
immune response going from being a weak
immune response to being a strong immune
response and if we look at the black
line that I've labeled disease and we
follow that line what you will see is
that it results in a u-shaped curve in
which when our immune response is low
host damage can be high because of a
lack of an ability to completely control
or clear an infectious agent and as we
follow that disease curve along we can
see that in the presence of a strong
immune response we can also have a high
degree of post damage this time being
caused by the pathology caused by the
exuberant immune response being
initiated in the context of infection so
again we can have damage to our tissue
being caused by either and a weak immune
and a weak immune response not
controlling an infection or an
over-exuberant immune response causing
immune mediated pathology with the
stippled line drawn in the middle what I
am illustrating and the hypothesis that
I am bringing to our discussion today is
that if host damage shows a male bias I
would predict it would
in cases where an weakened immune
response leads to an inability to
completely control an infection whereas
for infectious diseases where we see a
female bias in the severity of disease I
would hypothesize that this is being
caused by an over exuberant immune
response contributing to tissue damage
now to add to the complexity of what
we'll be discussing today these types of
sex differences and immune responses are
not stagnant over our life course we
find that these differences do in fact
change over our life course in which at
younger ages our immune responses both
in utero as well as prior to puberty
tend to be higher in males as compared
with females so if we just for the sake
of an example follow innate immune
responses specifically inflammatory
immune responses you'll see that these
inflammatory immune responses tend to be
higher in males prior to puberty but
then become higher in females after
puberty and through our reproductive
years
however after reproductive senescence we
find that in older age inflammatory
responses tend to be skewed toward males
once again much of what I'm going to be
focused on today is going to be sex
differences during adulthood so during
our reproductive ages but I think this
is an important caveat to keep in mind
that much of what I will be discussing
may not be completely applicable to the
conditions in either older age or prior
to puberty so I would like to begin our
analysis of data considering females of
reproductive ages have more severe
influenza so during the 2009 h1n1
pandemic
there were several correlates associated
with more severe outcome in this case
greater likelihood of hospitalization
with severe
disease age being of reproductive ages
so ages 16 to 45 years of age was
associated with more severe disease
being pregnant was associated with more
severe disease and having any
comorbidity associated with things like
obesity heart disease were associated
with more severe disease during the 2009
pandemic we heard a lot about these
three variables but we heard a lot less
about was the observation that just
merely being female
so this included females that were not
pregnant but being female was in fact a
comorbidity or a correlate associated
with more severe outcome from influenza
we can recreate this in animal models in
which working with c57 black 6 mice
inoculated in this case with a highly
pathogenic form of influence of
influenza that I would say most closely
mimics the 1918 strain of h1n1 when we
inoculate male and female mice of
similar ages so these are roughly ten
weeks of age with our reproductive ages
for mice what we find are that females
experience greater morbidity we have
several ways that we can measure
morbidity changes in body temperature or
one such measure and in mice they become
hypothermic when they become very ill so
as you can see we get greater
hypothermia and female mice as compared
with males females are also
significantly less likely to survive
infection as compared with males when we
measure the amount of virus in the lungs
and we do this using a method referred
to as a tcid 50 so if we're looking at
the log 10 tcid 50 units this is just a
fancy way of saying viral copies when we
look at this in the lungs at various
time points during the first week after
inoculation with this
virulent strain of h1n1 what we find are
that males and females do not show a
difference in either peak viral titers
or in the reduction or clearance of
virus from the lungs but again this was
a highly virulent strain so we only
looked at responses during the first
week post inoculation prior to where
females began dying so if you look at
that survival curve the depth of females
creates a bias and so in a laboratory
setting we limited our analysis to where
the bias the survival bias could not
influence our data however when we
looked at lots of different
pro-inflammatory proteins and I only
have one pictured here tumor necrosis
dr. alpha what we found was that
inflammatory proteins in the lungs were
induced in both males and females so
males are in fact inducing an
inflammatory response but it was not
nearly to the degree that we saw in our
females and females we were seeing
anywhere from a 60 as we have shown here
to an almost a hundredfold increase in
several proteins in the lungs suggesting
that females may be experiencing greater
immunopathology leading to the reduced
survival that we see in females of
reproductive ages now working with a
less pathogenic strain of influenza this
is the 2009 h1n1 influenza if we
inoculate male and female mice this time
the mice don't die this was a left less
pathogenic influenza virus but when we
look at morbidity and here we're looking
at the body mass of these animals
because when animals get sick they don't
eat we can't ask their animals how they
feel so we need objective measures to
tell us that they've gotten sick this
time females are in white males are in
the black filled symbols and what we
find are that females get sicker than
males they lose more of their body mass
as compared with the males males are
returning back to baseline which is
that stippled line that you see that
stipple horizontal line there returning
back to baseline faster but now because
not everybody is dying we can actually
measure virus titers for a longer
duration of time and what we find when
we look at peak viral titers by Bayes
post inoculation or we look at the
beginning of clearance of virus at nine
days or when there's complete clearance
at 14 days post inoculation we see no
sex difference when we evaluate
pulmonary function so maybe this is even
better than looking at measures of
morbidity like body mass and body
temperature changes over the course of
infection we can actually measure the
functioning of the lungs in our animals
and when we measure the functioning of
the lungs in our animals in this case 14
days post inoculation
so after virus has been completely
cleared from the lungs what we find when
we measure this abbreviated measure
which I have indicated here as the DFC
oh we're looking at the diffusion
capacity of the lungs so this is the
ability of there to be adequate exchange
of oxygen and co2 in the lungs the blue
stipple lines indicate the physiological
range of MOC infected animals both males
and females where we see absolutely no
difference but what we see among
infected animals 14 days after
inoculation is that males have returned
to baseline pulmonary function females
still have not returned to baseline
pulmonary function despite having
cleared the virus when we look and panel
D at gross inflammation in the lungs you
can see that males which are in the left
panel females in the right we have more
inflammation in females which is
represented or quantified in panel e
where we find that females have
cumulatively more inflammation in their
lungs long after virus has been cleared
indicating that in fact we were correct
females do in fact have more
immunopathology than males so what
to be protecting nails well one protein
that we have observed to be up regulated
in males as compared with females is a
growth factor referred to as anther
regulan and abbreviated 8rg in our
slides if we look in panels a and B what
we see is that 14 days after inoculation
with 2009 h1n1 influenza males have
significantly more cells producing info
regulan in their lungs as compared with
females again a growth factor associated
with repair in panel C if we look at the
expression of the ampere regulan gene so
this is measuring mRNA by quantitative
rt-pcr we find that female males excuse
me have significantly more infrared oh
and mRNA in their lungs of compared with
females working with collaborators
specifically Michael Chan at the
University of Hong Kong they have gone
on to evaluate the production of an
irregular in primary human alveolar
epithelial cells following infection
with a seasonal strain of h1n1 and they
also observe that there is greater
production or greater expression of
amber regulan mRNA in cells taken from
human male donors as compared with
emails suggesting a translational
component to this observation of
increased repair of tissue in males as
compared with females well we began to
wonder what could be some of the factors
mediating the sex difference in the
outcome of influenza and to a begin to
address the potential role that sex
steroid hormones which we know are
differentially produced in males and
female to begin to determine the role
that this may be playing in influenza
pathogenesis we conducted a simple
experiment in which we took out the
testes and males so we gonna tectum eyes
male
abbreviated GPX which means we took out
the testes thereby bringing testosterone
concentrations to non detectable levels
we doughnut optimized females again
abbreviated GDX which means we took out
the ovaries of females thereby reducing
both estrogen and progesterone levels to
non-detectable ranges and what we find
when we look at markers of morbidity and
mortality which are illustrated here we
find that the sex difference is
eliminated both males and females get
equally sick they lose similar
percentages of their body mass they both
experience a similar degree of
hypothermia and they both experience
similar death rates as compared with
each other
so we now knew that sex steroid hormones
were important regulators of this sex
difference in the pathogenesis of
influenza infection another observation
that we made early on was that if we
compared our gonna dec demise males with
gonadal E intact males those males that
no longer had testosterone were
significantly less likely to survive an
influenza infection as compared with
their go Natalie intact counterparts but
this was not due to differences in viral
titers in the lungs again using this
tcid 50 med method excuse me for
measuring or quantifying the amount of
virus in the lungs there was no effect
of castration on the amount of virus in
the lungs but we've since gone on to
show that what that testosterone
depletion does is it increases the
severity of influenza infection and so
one way that we can show this in a proof
of principle way using mice is to
compare good Natalie intact animals with
animals or males that have had their
testes removed and then males that have
had their testes removed but have been
administered exogenously time-release
capsule
testosterone abbreviated T when we give
testosterone back to within the
physiological range which is what we
have in our upper left panel when we
infect these animals with our 2009 h1n1
strain of influenza what we find is that
testosterone significantly protects
males so do not Ekta my's males given
testosterone do not lose nearly as much
of their body mass as compared with
males that have no testosterone this is
not causing differences in the titers of
virus in the lungs so these males have a
similar peak viral titers as well as
clearance a virus but what this does do
is testosterone again the animals that
are illustrated in the black bars of the
lower right hand corner when we look at
inflammation over time we find that the
reduction in inflammation is faster in
males that have been treated with
testosterone so let's look at some
histology to see what this looks like
so again 14 days after inoculation so
these animals have cleared virus there
is no longer virus present yet when we
look at the lungs of infected nails that
have either not been treated with
testosterone or who have been treated
with testosterone we find that
inflammation is significantly greater
and you can see this in the blown-up
images at the bottom of this slide have
significantly more peri vascular
inflammation as indicated by these
triangles peri bronchial inflammation as
indicated by the star as well as
alveolar inflammation as indicated by
these carrots it's not to say that males
treated with testosterone have no
residual inflammation they do but it's
not to the same degree as males with no
testosterone another observation that we
have made with regard to testosterone is
that t-cells with
are absolutely integral for antiviral
defenses these are cells are absolutely
necessary for clearing a virus but once
a virus like influenza has been cleared
from the lungs and we no longer need
these cells they are they undergo
apoptosis they exit the lungs and the
lungs then enter into a repair state and
what we find when we look at total cd8
positive T cells which is on the panel
on the far left males that have been
gonna wreak demised but treated with
testosterone they have these cells
present we have teeth they have T cells
in their lungs when virus is present so
at nine days post inoculation
but after virus has been cleared in
males that have been treated with
testosterone you see a more rapid
decline in the total numbers of these
cells in the lungs as compared with
males that have not been treated with
testosterone we see an identical pattern
when we look at virus specific cd8 T
cells so that's what's indicated by
tetramer we can use tetra MERS to label
influenza specific T cells we can also
look at the production of cytokines
including interferon gamma by our cd8
positive T cells and whichever marker we
use what we find is that males that are
treated with testosterone clear these
cells faster from their lungs as
compared with males that do not have
just aa stirone it's not to say that all
cell populations are being reduced by
testosterone importantly regulatory T
cells which are abbreviated T reg are
actually increased in the presence of
testosterone during influenza infection
and so in panel a using markers
including cd25
and Fox p3 as well as cd4 to identify
these regulatory t-cells we find that as
virus is getting cleared the proportion
of regulatory t-cells remain elevated
and male
that have been treated with testosterone
and decline more rapidly in males that
have an absence of testosterone in
circulation there are several proteins
that are produced by regulatory t-cells
and mediate their regulatory activities
including il-10 which is not
differentially produced in the lungs of
males with or without testosterone but
tgf-beta which is another regulatory
protein integral in down regulating
inflammation is produced at
significantly greater quantities in the
lungs of males that have been treated
with testosterone we know that these
effects are being mediated by the
androgen receptor and so the only way
that any of our steroid hormones can
have their biological effects is by
binding to androgen responding excuse me
to their specific hormone receptors the
hormone receptor or testosterone can be
either the androgen receptor abbreviated
AR but it is important and I'm sure many
of you remember from biology or med
school courses that androgens like
testosterone can be converted and
thematically into estrogens to bind to
estrogen receptors and to show that our
effects were being mediated
predominantly by the androgen receptor
again abbreviated AR we treated mice
with a commonly used cancer drug that
actually blocks the androgen receptor
referred to as flute amide so I have the
chemical structure of this flute amide
located here in the upper panel for
proof of principle to show that it
adequately blocks the androgen receptor
we can measure an androgen dependent
organ like the seminal vesicles to show
the efficacy of our treatment and when
we test this in the bottom panel in
animals that have been treated with
testosterone as well as mine and then
infected with the 2009 h1n1 influenza as
you can see males that have been treated
with those testosterone as well as nude
amide
respond very similar me so they
experienced a similar degree of
morbidity as males that have absolutely
no testosterone in circulation so they
experienced greater changes in their
body mass as well as their body
temperature as compared with males that
have been treated with testosterone
alone so we know that testosterone is
integral in that protection for males
so what could protect females well we
know that when we castrate females when
we take out their ovaries these females
respond to infection and experience a
similar rate of death as compared with
females that have their gonads which
shocked us we take out or we bring
estrogen and progesterone levels to non
detectable levels and these females are
responding to infection in an identical
manner to females that have circulating
estrogen presumably have circulating
estrogen and progesterone there's no
difference in their in their viral
titers in their lungs but when we looked
at the estrus cycle of these animals
what we found was that being infected
with influenza significantly disrupts
the estrus cycle which for mice is the
reproductive cycle it's what we would
refer to as the menstrual cycle in mice
their estrus cycle was significantly
increased and this was predominantly
caused by an increase in the stage of
estrus called die Astra's which is when
both estrogen and progesterone are at
their nadir suggesting that influenza is
disrupting female reproductive cycle
making a go Natalie intact
female more similar to an a very
optimized female so what happens if we
give hormones that well one hormone that
we have given back is progesterone which
is notoriously known for being
anti-inflammatory and because we knew
that influenza infection disrupts the
reproductive cycle of females causing a
persistent state of die
estrous or causing a persistent state of
low progesterone and low estrogen we've
wondered can hormone replacement therapy
improve the outcome of influenza and
females we've done this with both
progesterone and estrogen but I'd like
to walk you through our story with
progesterone because those are some of
our most recent data so when
progesterone crosses the lipid bilayer
of a cell to bind to cells to bind to
its receptor located in lots of
different cell types ranging from
various epithelial cells to diverse
immune cells the binding of progesterone
to the progesterone receptor can
actually block the activity of
inflammatory proteins including NF
kappa-b
which is illustrated here in this
cartoon the progesterone progesterone
receptor complex can also translocate
the nucleus of a cell where it can bind
to a progesterone response element
located on a stretch of DNA where it can
actually transcriptionally regulate the
production of proteins and growth
factors many of which can actually
dampen inflammation so there are two
ways by which progesterone binding to
its progesterone can reduce inflammation
so we wanted to know could giving
females exogenous progesterone at
physiological concentrations improve the
outcome of influent of influenza knowing
now that influenza is an inflammatory
mediated disease so we've treated
females with progesterone so females
that are treated with progesterone in
these graphics are in the closed cymbals
females that have not been treated with
progesterone are in the open cymbals and
what we find is that following
inoculation with our 2009 h1n1 influenza
female mice treated with progesterone
experienced less morbidity as compared
with females not treated with
progesterone
which is indicated in panel a as well as
in panel B using either temperature or
clinical behavioral scoring in order to
assess morbidity similar to what I
showed with testosterone in males when
we look at virus titers as in panel C we
find that there's no difference either
in peak virus titers or in the clearance
of virus from the lungs there is also no
difference in the depth of cells
following influenza infection and we can
measure this looking at a marker
referred to as LD h LD h is an enzyme
released from dying cells and when we
measure this in homogeneous of lung
tissue at various time points following
inoculation we find that during peak
viral infection you have the the
greatest amount of cell death but there
is no difference based on whether these
females are being treated with
progesterone and as virus is cleared you
get a reduction in the death of cells
one protein that we did observe to be
significantly increased in the context
of progesterone was that growth factor
that I referred to earlier and for AG
Yulin whether we look at amber regulan
mRNA expression in the lungs of females
treated with progesterone as well as
females not treated with progesterone we
find that treatment with progesterone
significantly increases the mRNA as well
as amber regulan protein production in
the lungs of females during influenza
infection we also find so again speaking
to this growth factor with more growth
factor you're going to get less damage
we're going to have greater repair of
lung tissue with increased repair of
lung tissue there's going to be less
protein being released into the bronco
alveolar spaces we can measure this by
looking at the amount of protein present
in Branko alveolar lavage
abbreviated ba L in panel a the amount
of protein contained in this lavage
fluid and what we find is that emails
that have been treated with progesterone
have less protein in their lungs as
compared in the bronco alveolar spaces
to be more specific as compared with
females treated with progesterone we
also find that proliferation of cells is
increased in the presence of
progesterone during influenza infection
which is abbreviated in piano B iae so
the way that we can measure cellular
proliferation is to look at the
expression of a marker referred to as
ki-67 and what we have in panel B is the
quantification of data from many animals
both mock infected as well as influenza
infected again abbreviated IAB and you
can see based on our cumulative data
females treated with infected females
treated with progesterone have
significantly greater proportions of
ki67 positive cells and in panel C we
just have the images representative
images to show you that among infected
females treated with progesterone you
have a greater degree of staining for
ki-67 which is illustrated by this dark
brown punctate staining which although
many cells have this staining we were
quite interested to see that you see
such a profound amount of staining in
the epithelial barrier again looking at
pulmonary function so we talked about
this earlier this lung diffusing
capacity or gas exchange that's exchange
of oxygen and co2 in the lungs and what
we found was that this measure of
pulmonary function with the stippled
lines illustrating the physiological
range for mock infected animals
it's females that have been treated with
progesterone that return back to
baseline pulmonary function faster than
females that have been
pleaded progesterone to further
illustrate mechanistically that
progesterone is having its reparative or
protective effects during influenza
infection through ampere regulan
signaling we want we studied and and or
excuse me we compared the responses to
progesterone in females that were
wild-type females so these are
genetically intact emails and compared
them with what are referred to as ampere
regulan knockout females so these are
females that do not have the ample
regulan gene within their genome when we
treat these females with progesterone
and infect them with influenza what we
find is that treatment progesterone
treatment of ampere regulan depleted
females does not protect them from flu
they experience greater morbidity as
compared with wild-type females and they
experience greater inflammation as
compared with wild-type emails so
deletion of ampere regulan reverses the
protective effects of progesterone I'd
last like to make the point that we can
use synthetic forms of progesterone
including lever nor gesture all so this
would be a form of progesterone that is
found in several types of birth control
if we give females lever no gesture all
which is abbreviated LNG very similar to
what we see with progesterone these
females are in fact protected against
influenza they experience less morbidity
as illustrated in panels a and B despite
having no difference in the ability to
control the viral infection which again
has suggested to us that it's about
modulating the inflammation as opposed
to the control of infection that
mediates the protective effects of these
progestin z' in email nice another
mechanism that can protect female
is giving them a vaccine so vaccinating
females against influence turns out to
be a wonderful way to improve protection
males and females differ in their
responses to diverse vaccine so while I
will be focused on influenza I do not
want you to think there is something
singularly unique about influenza there
are actually several vaccines that are
given to children adults aged adults
that when we look at the immune response
we find it is greater in emails as
compared with males
the downside of greater immune
activation could be that females are
also significantly more likely to report
adverse reactions to vaccines so where
investigators have bothered to look and
compare males and females statistically
they report adverse reactions being
higher or more likely to be reported in
females as compared with males but as
you can see especially among children
there are several studies that have not
partitioned and analyzed data by stats
so again turning our attention to
influenza these are data from a human
trial of the trivalent inactivated
influenza abbreviated TIV so this is the
inactivated flu vaccine that is given
intramuscularly often referred to as the
flu shot and what we can see is that
whether females and males are given a
full dose so that's the dose that we all
receive when we go to receive our annual
flu vaccine or whether females and males
receive a half dose of the trivalent
inactivated flu vaccine females develop
higher hemagglutinin inhibition antibody
titers as compared with males what I
find remarkable is that females given a
half dose of the vaccine mount an immune
response
that is almost equivalent to that of
males that receive the full dose when we
look at the percentage of Saxony's
reporting adverse side effects we find
that whether we look at injection site
pain inflammation muscle pain or
headache females are significantly more
likely to report these adverse reactions
as compared with males now whether this
is a gender difference illustrating a
reporting bias or whether females are in
fact experiencing greater inflammation
has not been completely determined but I
would argue that based on our data we
might hypothesize that inflammation
could be greater in females as compared
with males resulting in a greater
reporting of these adverse side effects
but we can recreate these differences in
animal models using both killed
influenza vaccine as well as live
influenza vaccine again the live
influenza vaccine is the vaccine that is
given intranasally often referred to as
FluMist which is currently no longer
being offered in the United States
though it is being offered in several
other countries including Canada but
what we find in our mouse studies is
that if we give males and females again
of reproductive ages either the killed
influenza vaccine or alive influenza
vaccine and we measure antibody
responses so if we look in the upper
panel in response to the kill vaccine we
can look at total influenza specific IgG
titers or we can look at neutralizing
antibody titers so this is a very
functional assay in which we are able to
actually take serum from animals we even
do this with human samples and expose it
to virus and cells that are virally
infected and we look at the ability of
this antibody to block the ability of
virus to infect cells very highly
functional assay and what we find is
females that have been vaccinated with
the kill vaccine developed higher
antibody responses ads compared with
nails using a live influenza vaccine we
find that females also produce higher
antibody titers so NAB is just a fancy
abbreviation for neutralizing antibody
titers when we look in the lungs of
females that have received a live
influenza vaccine we find that females
have more antibody secreting cells in
their lungs I've compared with males
when we also look in the lungs for those
cd8 positive T cells those T cells that
have very important antiviral properties
and we look at various populations of
memory cells and what I have pictured
here for you today are the t RM cells
which are just the resident memory T
cells these are very important in in the
memory response and env protection
against challenge from influenza what we
find are that these resident memory T
cells are found in a higher in a higher
degree to get greater numbers of these
cells in the lungs of vaccinated females
as compared with nails well one thing
that we can more readily do in mice than
we could in humans is we can actually
challenge them with live virus it's not
to say we can't do this in humans it's
just a more challenging IRB approval
protocol so in this case what we do is
we challenge our animals with a drift
variant of the 2009 h1n1 influenza
vaccine or excuse me virus and this
variant this drip variant has a mutation
in position 166 in the hemagglutinin
head and so in panel B here what this is
based on our data from humans in which
beginning in 2013
this mutation at position 166 of a k2
Accu occurred and has actually become
the predominant mutation that we now see
in circulating strains of h1n1 and
seasonal e when we inoculate vaccinated
males and females or challenged
vaccinated males and females with this
drift Arian we find that in the upper
panel females are able to clear virus
faster so again using that tcid 50
method to measure the amount of virus
and the lungs of males and females
females are clearing virus significantly
faster than males and when we look at
morbidity following infection females
are not actually experiencing any
morbidity and they're experiencing
significantly less morbidity as compared
with their vaccinated male counterparts
suggesting that vaccine efficacy may be
greater in females as compared with
nails the last point that I would like
to briefly make is that I do not think
this is limited to influenza more
recently we've been working with
immunization protocols against malaria
parasite and what we find is that
following vaccination with irradiated
malaria parasites and these are
irradiated sporozoites
females again adult females of
reproductive ages generate higher
antibody responses to the vaccine as
compared with their male counterparts
I'm showing you in the upper panel their
titration curves if we look at the area
under the curve you find that females
have higher antibody responses of
compared with nails looking at area
under the curve looking at total IgG
titers in the bottom left panel or
looking at the titer of antibody when
that antibody crosses the od1 so
regardless of how we slice these data we
find the females
hire anybody responses in this case to
an irradiated or azoic vaccine against
malaria when we challenged our male and
female mice with malaria parasites and
in this case we use the mosquito bite
challenge what we find is that females
that have been challenged with malaria
develop a significantly higher cd8
positive T cell response this time in
their liver because that is where the
malaria parasite goes females have
higher t-cell responses and when we
measure parasite burden in their liver
so looking at in this case Plasmodium
RNA copy numbers what we find is that
vaccinated females have virtually
undetectable levels of parasite RNA
whereas vaccinated males though they do
have less Peris less of a parasite load
than unvaccinated or naive males they
still have detectable parasites and a
level of parasite detection that is
significantly higher than their
vaccinated female counterparts so what I
hope that I have showed you today is
that there are several modifiers of sex
differences and infectious disease
outcome I've only discussed but one of
those modifiers sex hormones I've shown
you that testosterone can protect
against severe disease outcome in males
I've shown you that gesture own can
protect against severe disease outcome
in females and I've shown you that when
comparing males and females vaccination
may be one of the best ways to keep both
males and females within the range of an
immune response that leads to the least
amount of host damage and so with that I
would like to end and paint several of
my collaborators at Johns Hopkins at the
FDA the students who have contributed
significantly to the work that I've
presented as well as my funding sources
so thank you
Thank You dr. Klein for that
presentation it's time for QA if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
to click on the sidon button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question we will follow up with you via
email after the presentation let's get
started our first question is Thank You
Enza and the other infectious diseases
are most severe in the elderly do you
see the same sex differences in older
aged aged individuals and what about
children that's a great question and the
comment that I made that these sex
differences are by no means stagnant
they do in fact change over our life
course so if we take influenza as but
one example we find that influence the
severity of influenza the severe in all
children and all older adults data show
that it is significantly more severe in
boys of compared with girls prior to
puberty as well as in older aged men as
compared with women in fact there are
even beautiful data that have come out
of various parts of Asia showing that in
community-dwelling
older individuals who have been
vaccinated you're significantly more
likely to see breakthrough cases of
influenza among vaccinated males as
compared with females suggesting that
the vaccine efficacy may be even worse
among older males as compared with
females
thank you for that answer we'll wrap up
with one more question and that question
is most vaccines are given to children
before puberty are the same sex
differences in vaccine efficacy observed
if so what is the mechanism mediating
these differences well that is a great
question and and a question that we
continue to give a lot of attention to
in my laboratory what we do in fact find
is that sex differences are reported in
children under the age of five in which
in particular antibody responses are
often reported to the greater following
vaccination of females or girls as
compared with boys because these are
children under the age of five they've
not yet gone through puberty they do not
have those circulating testosterone and
progesterone concentrations that I was
referring to earlier in my in my talk so
what we've begun thinking is that there
could either be genetic or maybe even
epigenetic differences between males and
females that could be mediating some of
these differences and that while I've
given you evidence that sex steroid
hormones can regulate the immune
response they are by no means the sole
mediators of these differences in our
immune responses or in the efficacy of
vaccines there's growing information or
growing data illustrating that not only
can there be genetic differences but
that differences between males and
females in the composition of our
microbiome can impact our immune systems
differently and result in differences
not only in vaccine efficacy but maybe
even in development of autoimmune
diseases which also show a sex bias with
over 80% of all autoimmune disease
patients being female so
there's still much to be learned I would
like to once again thank dr. Klein for
her presentation do you have any final
comments for including me in this lab
Reid's webinar I think that bringing
diverse science to the masses through
online learning is a very very valuable
tool and I am honored to have been here
and I hope that everybody has learned a
little bit more about the consideration
of sex as a biological variable and may
go back to their own labs or to their
own patients and think that there may be
some fundamental differences between men
and women which means we may have to be
treated differently in order to be
treated equally thank you so much thank
you once again
decline I would also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 14th 2017 you will
receive an email from labrys letting you
know when this webcast will be available
to replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye